hey guys Lucy here with a quick gamespot
news update for you Microsoft has
confirmed that they're cutting the UK
retail price of the xbox one to just 299
pounds 19 9 pence as part of a sales
promotion which is a long-winded way of
saying there's an Xbox one price cut the
discount is the latest development in a
long-running series of revisions to the
xbox one's retail price as part of a
wider bid to remain competitive with the
industry's current best selling home
console the PlayStation 4 go it launched
in November 2013 at 429 pounds the xbox
one's price was cut to 400 pounds just
four months later then in May 2014
Microsoft's crap connect as a mandatory
accessory and began listing the console
for 350 pounds by September that version
was cut to 330 pounds as part of a price
promotion which microsoft said was
temporary at first but became standard
over time a spokesperson for microsoft
said this is a UK only retail promotion
and offers great value for fans looking
to buy an xbox one the head is the
launch of 2015 highly anticipated games
like the witcher 3 wild hunt metal gear
solid 5 the phantom pain and batman
arkham night along with xbox exclusives
such as rise of the Tomb Raider bots a
motorsport 6 and halo 5 Guardians sony
announced in march this year at GDC 2015
that it sold 20 point two million
playstation 4 consoles worldwide
Microsoft's numbers to the end of last
year indicate around 10 million xbox one
consoles have shipped so what do you
make of the latest price drop is it
enough to make you want to buy an xbox
one or do you already have one you're a
bit annoyed that you could have got it
for cheaper of course let me know in the
comment section below and bra the latest
gaming news make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot
you